Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on guys. This is.
Rob and we are picking back up again with tales from the dark multiverse.
This time we're focusing on flashpoint.
So a little bit of an explanation here for people who are not familiar with the
flashpoint story.
My flash point is probably one of the most important stories of DC's done in a
long, long time, because that's the story that kicked off the new 52.
So the way this initially played out to kind of give a really quick rundown
explanation, and I believe that we did cover flashpoint on the channel.
So it should be down in the description if we did.
But the idea here is that at some point along the line,
very Alan decided to go back into the past and save his mom from dying at the
hands of ear barred thought. And the, the idea of barriers that if he did that,
then basically everything would happen the same way that it always did.
Except now he'd have his mom in his life.
The exact opposite happened that with Barry Allen's,
mom's basically surviving the, what it led to was the flashpoint universe.
It had this great big,
huge series of effects on the timeline so that when Joe chill went to go murder
Thomas and Martha Wayne in crime alley, he actually shot Bruce Wayne in step.
And Thomas Wayne became Batman and Martha Wayne became the joker that you ended
up having a war that broke out between the Atlantean and the a and the Amazons.
And that that's kind of been going on ever since Superman was taken by the
government, right? As soon as he landed on earth,
he was taken by the government. So he's never seen any kind of civilization.
There's no Superman Lois lane. There's, there's none of that stuff,
but it's just a really, really twisted and dark universe. Now,
the way this worked out was that very Alan's powers were initially lost to him.
And then ultimately he gained them back and then basically went back in time and
allowed his mom to die. And that kind of reset the timeline so to speak,
but it led into the creation of the new 52, right?
It was basically DC rebooting.
And so what this does is this picks up in that moment when Barry Allen and
Thomas Wayne were jump-starting very Allen's powers, right?
When they were basically getting his powers back in, back in the pike.
So he could basically kind of figure out what's going on.
You'll face off against ear farm when he made his presence known.
And then of course go back in time and let his mom die.
The difference here is that when that happens,
that ear Bard thought actually seems to strike that when Barry Allen does this,
that ear, Bart is just kind of running through the time stream.
But as Barry Allen's powers, come back to him, this kind of quote,
unquote lightning strike, right?
The speed force basically ends up throwing e-board fawn into the flashpoint
universe. And when he arrives here, he immediately kills Barry Allen, right?
Just like that, very Alan's gone. And so he,
barred fawn is the only speedster in this universe.
And what's kind of crazy about this is he looks at Barry and he says, man, like,
this is kind of wild, but,
but fate seems to have more or less stepped in with regards to EMR on arriving
here, Barry Allen being killed. And at that point he barred fonts kind of like,
okay, well,
if my existence was always tied into the idea of like being better than you
defeating you, you know, not necessarily killing you,
but I guess ultimately doing it one day and now Barry, Allen's dead.
E-board fun is kind of free. Right. It's kind of like, okay,
so I can just kind of do my thing in this place. Now,
Thomas Wayne immediately attacks him. Right?
Thomas Wayne immediately goes after him.
And then he Bartholin goes after Thomas Wayne. But as he does,
he begins to pick up on the memories and the thoughts, the feelings of,
of Bruce, I'm sorry,
of Thomas Wayne and realizes he's not in the main DC universe from [inaudible]
perspective. This is just the main DC universe. Right. Very analyst debt.
And it's like, wow, cool, awesome. But now that he learns,
it's an alternate reality where Bruce Wayne died instead of Thomas and Martha,
the things are totally different here. The things are darkly arrived.
And that's when he says like, this world is a gift. There's no real hope here.
Right? Like things are pretty bad. Things are pretty gloomy.
And I can build on that. Right. I can take this world and make it my own.
There's no unified justice league.
The superheroes who are here are scattered in,
divided the warring against one another.
There's no one to really challenge me in this place.
And so with that being the case,
we basically jumped over to Washington DC with the president of the United
States. And the president being here is,
it's kind of interesting because EMR thought basically took off where we don't
really know where he went to. But the president being here is this,
guy's basically just kind of a coward. These basically scared.
He's scared to death of the IDF,
the Amazons and the Atlantean are going to go to war. They're going to,
or at least they had been at war.
Other that one of them who will eventually conquer the United States, right.
Because the us doesn't really have the ability to stand against that kind of
power. But then in the middle of all of this, right? When,
when the president's like,
we don't have anybody that can stand against that kind of power, EMR,
Dawn smashes, the doors open, right.
Just goes ripping through and just starts taking out everybody. Right? Like,
like everybody who's here, the green lantern and the whole nine yards,
they all fall before EMR thumb because you can move faster than they can fake at
that point. There's really not much they can do.
And when he sends cyborg flying out of the place, right,
this isn't him flying out of the oval. That's what he tells the president.
I created you. You're here because of me.
And we end up finding out that the way this was supposed to play out.
And the reason why the president here is different than he was in the original
flashpoint story is because he thought and went into the past and then basically
set things up. So this guy would become president of the United States. Right?
Initially he was a soap opera actor.
This guy had no business ever becoming president of the United States,
but he dead right ear. Bardon kind of made it happen.
And the reason why is because this guy's cowardice is such to where he'll do
anything to make sure everything's okay, right? I mean,
this guy is terrified of confrontation. That kind of stuff. Now cyborg,
just jump back in. But he's atomized by, uh, by EMR thought almost immediately.
But the reason why he comes to me is he basically says like, you're,
you're a weak man,
but you are a weak man who is put into a wildly powerful position.
You will basically do anything I tell you to. And if I tell you that I can,
it's a war between the Amazons and the Atlanteans.
If I can that conflict and keep America shore safe, that in turn,
I want the United States, I want to, I want to own America.
You can keep running it. Right. That's fun. Do whatever you want with it.
But I want to be the one that basically owns it right when I come into the oval
office and I tell you that something done, that thing gets done, right?
Like that's, that's what he's shooting for now while all that's happening.
Because of the fact that the president basically allies himself with [inaudible]
and says, you know, this guy calls himself the flash that he's got,
the power that this power that he has will basically save us the United States
more or less rallies under him. Not a lot of people questioned him.
And the reason why is that in times of day, Spiration,
people will believe what they want to believe. Logic and reason.
They both go out the window, right?
People just believe what makes them feel happy? Well,
it makes them feel more comfortable. Now that's bad. That's a terrible,
terrible philosophy to have, but it's just how human beings are. Right.
It's how we as people are. The,
the important thing is that while Thomas is watching all that one thing to
understand, Barry is not going to come back, right? Very Alan's death.
There is no resurrection for him and any real form or fashion,
but Batman gets a message from Victor stone who backed up his brain,
basically revealing to him. The Superman project. Now the Superman project,
as we talked about kind of a little bit ago,
was the idea that when Superman landed on earth,
he was taken by the federal government and then tested,
examined all that kind of stuff, but never became the Superman that,
that we know why the guy who basically leaves superheroes into a better
tomorrow, right here, United superheroes,
all under this idea that they could become better.
People that's Superman does not exist, right? No one's ever heard of him before.
No one knows he exists. Right? There is just one of these things. We're just,
nobody's aware that it's there. Now, the funny thing about that,
this is one of the things that I love the most about EMR thought is when you
transition back to him and he's talking to them president,
and that eventually transitions and talks to Thomas Wayne,
that he kind of gives us this really,
really cool breakdown perception of Barry Allen,
how it is that he truly sees Barry Allen, because more often than not,
whenever we see IA, Bardon discussing the nature of Berry,
it's usually done with regards to his desire to take Barry Allen down.
But because of the fact that Barry Allen's now dead,
that is kind of how he Bardon really views him.
And it's not really anything honorable, like, you know, very aloe.
Wasn't the greatest man I ever met in the suction. He died.
It's not really anything like that.
Instead of he considers Barry Allen to be a selfish person, right.
A very Island to kind of be no measure of a superhero at all.
And he actually is not wrong here. Right? He's, he's really not wrong.
And that's, what's so, so interesting because he kind of breaks it down.
He says,
for all the superhero antics that Barry Allen engaged in at the end of the day,
he ran back in time and save his mom's life. He's like I,
as the reverse flash understand the time is a nuance thing.
It's almost like threading a needle, right?
You can't just go lumbering in there like a bull in a China shop and just start
doing what it is that you want to do,
because it's going to have effects on time.
You have to understand how time works before you manipulate it.
Barry Allen did not know and did not care in all reality that very Alan cared
nothing about the nuance of time.
Barry Allen decided that one day he's going to save his mom's life.
And so he just ran back through time and he saved his mom's life with no thought
to the consequences of the actions that he was engaging in,
not just in so far as how it would affect his life,
but how would it affect everybody else's life around him and what it led to was
this terrible, horrible world that you guys live in right now,
Barry Allen created that.
And it's one of these things where Batman kind of challenges them a little bit
and says, you know, okay, well then here's my question.
What you're telling me here,
your entire existence was based around the notion of Barry Allen living.
So what's the purpose of your existence now, right?
What's the purpose behind your life? Why do you even exist anymore?
And it's almost kind of like ear barred fonts thrown into this existential
crisis. And instead of answering the question he deflects and he's like, well,
what about you, Thomas Wayne, look at you. You know, like,
all you're doing now is you're not a hero, right?
You're not trying to save the world or even your city.
You're just a man obsessed with destroying criminals, screaming at the world,
making it pay for your pain. That's all you really are.
The funny thing about that is that's Bruce Wayne and that's,
what's kind of interesting is that Bruce and Thomas are very similar in that
regard. And the, the, the whole gist behind is that you kind of get this,
this interesting situation where Thomas Wayne is like, okay.
So Barry Allen told me [inaudible] came from a time. Or at least the, the,
the world that Barry Allen came from that Bruce Wayne survived and myself and
Martha Wayne died.
And like any father they'd want their children to survive before themselves.
Right. Especially somebody as young as Bruce,
because he never got a chance to live a life. And so because of that,
Thomas Wayne kind of starts mulling this over when Ybarra fawns starts kicking
off the idea of, Hey,
I can go back and I can fix things in this universe so that your son never died.
So that Martha never goes in same so that you never have to become Batman.
You guys can live the life that you always imagine, you guys living,
I can make that happen. And when Thomas is kind of like, well,
then will you do it right? Will you save them? Will you bring my,
will you bring my boy back? The responsible EBAC thrawn is not a chance,
but I could, but I'm not going to, and I'm not going to because I don't have to.
Right. And then just leaves. There's not a single hope out there.
That's not going to happen. But Thomas Wayne hopes that it could happen. Now,
there are two main things that happen here, right?
Two main things that come out of this,
the first is that looking at the nature between [inaudible] Fon and Barry Allen,
that [inaudible] chased Allen, he chased Barry out.
And the reason why was because he had his own motivations, right.
Trying to become better, trying to prove, you know, whatever it was.
But he was obsessed with, with Barry out. The fact that Barry Allen is dead,
basically left ear barred, kind of out there trying to figure himself out.
And what he does is he reverts back to what he knows by presenting Thomas Wayne,
with the possibility that he could save his family and then choosing not to
Thomas Wayne will become obsessed with that idea.
And he will chase down EMR thought.
And so basically [inaudible] now has his own version of quote-unquote EMR
thought a person obsessed with him for the purpose of trying to achieve a
particular goal.
The second thing that comes out of this is that we're kind of presented with
this idea. That hope is not simply just a concept. Hope is a tangible thing,
right? Hope is a, is a realistic, tangible thing.
You can't necessarily touch it, but it's palpable, right?
That the way in which the world functions right now is because it's a world with
no real hope,
but as hope begins to grow in this world from various people due to various
circumstances, the world can actually become a better place.
What you end up doing is switching over to metropolis about 200 meters below
ground with cyberwar,
who's kind of put his mind inside of a robot body and Thomas Wayne.
And they're basically traveling to meet with, meet with Superman, right?
To see Superman for the very first time and to basically release him.
The other part of this is that Ebert Vaughn is finally maintaining his promise
after about a week to end the war between the Atlanteans and the,
and the Amazons. The first thing he does is he kills Aquaman, right?
He basically says like, you know,
I had believed that the Amazonian queen would be more reasonable,
but this is a gift, right? You just came assuming,
presumably running at me with all the power and all the strength that you had.
And there's just, there's nothing you could really do. I've killed you. Now.
I can basically use you as a means to broker peace between wonder woman and the
Atlantans. And so what he does is he grabs the body of,
of Aquaman and then brings it to wonder woman drops it off in front of her and
says, this is a warning. You and your old gods are all finished,
but you guys are all done. America is mine. If you come here,
if you come to the United States, I will kill you all.
I will take all of you out. This is your warning.
There not be another one do not come here, stay away.
And it's kind of nuts because it basically seems to essentially end the
conflict. Like just like that. The war is basically done. Not from there.
It switches back over to a, to Thomas Lane and the sideboard.
And we end up finding out that with Superman being freed, of course,
because of the fact that it's kind of interesting thing that was covered here,
uh, with Superman, despite not having ever really met any human beings.
The overall gist is that DC kind of ties into the nature of Superman as being a
hopeful person. Superman likes to believe in the best of people.
And the results of this is that given the various psychological tests that were
done by a done on him by the federal government, Superman desire's friends.
And so with cyborg and Thomas Wayne presumed themselves as friends,
or they in turn managed to get them out, right. That's why he didn't Superman.
Didn't just immediately attack them because he was afraid of them or something
like that. I'm sure some of you guys are going to ask that.
And that's why I thought it was important to mention,
but basically he's just been sitting here absorbing solar radiation for like
five days, every single minute out in the daylight. And that's it, right?
Like every single minute of daylight for five days, he just hangs there,
absorbing all that energy. Now of course,
it's him basically bolstering his abilities, but still right as Superman,
who's wildly formidable from there.
What you end up getting is kind of like this, this,
these Atlantean shifts that are just sort of sitting out there right now,
a plan was formulated between Superman and between cyborg and Thomas Wayne.
But we didn't really know exactly what that plan was.
Instead when Eve Arthur's attention is drawn to these Atlantean,
these Atlantean ships,
they're just kind of sitting out there suddenly he's attacked by Superman.
And as far as I'm aware,
this is the first time we really get to see a one-on-one fight between Superman.
And [inaudible] what makes it even more interesting is it's flashpoint,
Superman versus Ybarra. I thought that's what makes this really, really,
really cool is because this is not like the wildly experienced knows exactly how
to handle [inaudible] version of Superman. They've never met right now.
This was a year and facing off against Superman in the DC universe because of
the fact that thought is a, is a huge enemy. Like the, the main enemy of, uh,
of Barry Allen, right? His, his arch arch arch nemesis.
And because of the fact that she ran has had dealings with EMR [inaudible] in
the past, he would know exactly how to handle this situation,
but we don't get that here. Instead, we kind of have EMR Dawn.
Who's really sort of analyzing the nature of Superman and kind of looking at
this and we get some really, really cool moments. That one,
he's not really scared of the idea of finding a Kryptonian so much as he's
worried about what it means, right?
The Superman embodies hope more so than that.
This Superman could take out all the Atlantean and all the Amazons on his own.
Right? And you get even goes as far as to say,
wonder woman and Aquaman just don't come close to the power of Superman here.
The other part of that is that Superman can hit him from any direction.
Unlike Barry Allen, who is like a, a Bishop on a chess board, right. Or a Rook,
he's not confined to moving in one singular direction, right?
It's not like diagonal or, or side-by-side, you know, horizontal or,
or a vertical only, he's like a queen piece. He can move in any direction.
And so fighting Superman means fighting in a three-dimensional space because he
can come from any direction, top to bottom left to right.
And any variation in between. And so, because of that,
e-board fawn is constantly on his guard, but then it goes as far as to say,
if Superman lands one punch on e-board fawn,
that'll be enough to take him out fast. And so, because of that,
it's really just bobbing and weaving it's dodging as best he can.
He does pick up on these small little moments, for example,
when Suzanne uses heat vision that has high frequency,
high-frequency photons shooting at light speed for the Superman,
can't really aim.
And it's kind of an interesting concept because it really begs the question when
Superman fires off heat vision, can he accurately aim?
Which is to say that if he sees you in point a and then you move to point B,
can you successfully track you? And the assumptions always been yes,
because this is always kind of how we've seen it play out.
But when you give it some thought,
the question is he really can he see through his heat vision to follow you?
What is that really how that works? I don't know, but I feel like it'd be,
it makes Superman a lot more interesting if he couldn't write,
if he was really just guessing, but it is a cool concept. It's on,
I'm curious post down in the common section, what you guys think, right.
Should Superman legitimately be able to track somebody while he's using his heat
vision or should the heat vision obscure his ability to see and keep him from
being able to track somebody with his eyesight?
Let me know when you guys think down there, but, uh, nonetheless the plan here,
what's not so much for Superman to kill. ELR thought that was not the plan.
The plan was for Superman to move [inaudible] to a particular location.
And the reason for that is because what Batman and what, uh,
what cyborg have done is they basically set up Sonics.
And the idea is to effectively defeat, uh,
defeat [inaudible] by using ultrasonics. That's basically what it is, right?
To literally use sound,
to kind of encase him and to control him and to sort of keep him locked off.
Now, the other part of that is that Batman goes to pull a gun, right,
and goes to fire a shot. But the response is cyborg is no. We made an a,
we made a deal with Superman that we were not going to kill Ybarra thought.
And we're Batman is almost incapacitated for a moment. He takes out cyborg.
And then his whole stance is EMR. Thorn was never my target. I want my son.
And so he fires off a shot and he basically says like his whole stance here,
what Sue effectively convinced EMR or get ear by thorn to know that Batman could
kill, right? The Batman could actually take them out,
but orchestrating this plan that Batman could kill EMR thong.
And the only way that EMR bond is going to have to spend his days not worrying,
you know, not looking over his shoulder, worrying is today.
The day the Batman takes me out is to give him the world that he wants to give
him a world where his son exists, where Bruce Wayne was safe. And that's,
what's kind of bonkers because what you end up also getting here is Batman
basically revealing that it was never his intention to actually kill you.
Bart thought it was his intention to kill Superman.
And so he grabs a kryptonite bullet and fires it off, kill Superman on the spot.
Right. And then just says like EMR thrawn, it's time for you to do your thing,
right? Like while that's happening, you have the ships of like the Amazons.
And like, like, like the invisible ships, like Amazon's in Atlanta,
but just come flooding into this whole location.
And you ended up finding out that with EMR fond,
doing what he did by showing up on the doorstep of wonder woman with the body of
Alco man dropping it off and saying, don't come here.
But what he actually did is he United them. Right.
He killed the King of the Atlanteans dropped their body off at wonder woman.
And by doing that, the Atlanteans now work alongside the Amazonians, right? The,
the Amazons. And so, because that,
they're a singular unified force numbering in the millions. Right? And they go,
as far as to say, like,
we're going to conquer the United States and understand you are right about one
thing, the old gods are basically dead. So we made a deal with new ones,
essentially wonder woman. And the,
the combined Atlantean Amazon force made a deal with dark side of the new gods
and boom tubes just start opening everywhere.
So essentially para demons just come flooding in. It's absolutely nuts.
Now from there, we never really get to see what happens. Instead.
Batman tells that you're barred thought get out of here, right? Like run,
give me the world that we agreed to. Right?
You agreed that you would give me my son back, do that. Right? Like,
like do that understand you're not bound by Barry Allen anymore. Right?
It's kind of like this, this quick little voice of reason.
You're not bound by Barry Allen anymore.
This world can be anything you want it to be right. This world is 100% yours,
right? It's it's 100% yours. Like it doesn't belong to anybody else.
And in that moment, EMR, thrawn realizes yes,
it is his ability to manipulate time to travel back and forth through time
basically means he can remake this world in any number of ways.
EMR thought effectively becomes God. And that's,
what's kind of crazy is the world changes based on what he wants,
but he can travel 30 years into the past and maybe like save the life of Bruce
Wayne, getting in trouble 30 years into the past again.
And maybe only Martha Wayne dies and Bruce and Thomas survive.
Then he travels into 30 years in the past again.
And then maybe it's just like Bruce and Thomas who die in Martha Wayne survives.
Right. Does she become that woman?
Take that concept and just extrapolate it across the board, right?
Any actor who's ever seen that's entertaining can become president of the United
States. Maybe he makes himself president for a little while.
Maybe he kinda messes things up and just sees what it's like when like wonder
woman in dark side,
fight to the death on earth and just engineer's things to happen. That way.
There's no limit to the possibilities of what [inaudible] can make out of the
earth.
And that's why we don't get a definitive ending to what this earth will look
like when EMR fond runs through time.
Because the possibilities of what the earth can look like, have no limits,
right? There's no telling what could happen.
And pretty much as we're told here any,
and all those possibilities will come to fruition,
they will actually take place. But regardless,
the world now belongs to [inaudible].
This dark multi-verse world belongs completely and totally to him.
Now what's really interesting here is that there is basically a dark multi-verse
EMR fond now.
So what I'm curious to see is how they're going to change that character,
what they're going to do with him. But with that being said, guys,
we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to come as explained to make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the Rob port. Do you guys enjoy this video?
Make sure you drop a like, and I will catch you all later.
[Inaudible]
[inaudible].